allora quando sbagliano mia chiesa
di disuguaglianze anziché porta
a una cosa di letteratura che che
diciamo mira consuma insomma un po il
mio pane
ho pensato riportare una opera d arte
contemporanea
perché per molte ragioni può credo che
ve le spiegherò ora ma soprattutto
perché diciamo moltissime persone anche
molte delle persone che mi circondano e
che io stimo molto hanno un grande
pregiudizio nei confronti dell'arte
contemporanea perché la considerano
diciamo classico comode in furbastri
legati alle grandi gallerie
insomma che fanno soldi intorno a a
degli oggetti il cui diciamo la cui
qualità insomma non è più facile
considerare semmai criteri su questo
sono sempre più sempre più difficili più
labili
invece io credo che ci siano ancora
molti molti artisti seri i quali sanno
come dire sanno attingere a quel nucleo
di verità che siamo soliti attribuire
all'arte del passato allora in questo
caso a proposito di disuguaglianze
ho portato dei four nights dei four
nights è un opera di william kentridge
noi qui non abbiamo l'opera nel senso
che è un film in pellicola in 16 mm di
sei minuti 6 minuti e mezzo che sta al
moma di new york e qui noi ci dovremmo
diciamo limitare a queste povere questi
poveri immagini facilmente scaricabili
dalla rete
quindi diciamo vi chiedo un po di forza
di immaginazione e di fi dargli un po di
quello che di raccolto dei four nights è
un'opera del 2003 di questo artista
sudafricano william kentridge dei four
nights il giorno per la notte kentridge
ha sempre lavorato lavora da sempre
sulla questione della colpa la questione
della colpa però l'opera in questione è
come credo sia visibile già da queste
piccole indizi non è diciamo un'opera
impegnata nel senso classico del termine
è semmai può passare addirittura come
una specie di come dire di filmino dal
sapore antico con con strane organismi
ecco sono questi puntini bianchi poi
riveleremo estranei organismi po vaganti
nello spazio
sembrerebbe un omaggio ai primordi del
cinema in effetti per molti aspetti che
entri c'e anche considerato infine
archeologo dell'immagine in movimento
ecco però più che una citazione erudita
è un'opera un opera d arte contemporanea
è un cortometraggio in pellicola tra
l'altro è un cortometraggio in pellicola
in un mondo di videoartisti in cui
diciamo che i video sono tutti iper
tecnologici sono tutti ad altissima
definizione faccio un nome che credo sia
il più noto bill viola o bill vaio e la
che dir si voglia noè maestro di questi
video iper tecnologici qui noi invece
abbiamo un cortometraggio in pellicola
semplicissimo che diciamo richiama un po
la lanterna magica del xvii secolo
richiama molto diciamo ha sullo sfondo
il lavoro pionieristico di georges
méliès meyer a quel grande
sperimentatore che tra otto e novecento
provava le potenzialità della cinepresa
più famoso dei suoi film quello il
viaggio sulla luna nel 1902 dove c'è
quella quella luna che sa che a
nell'occhio un tappo di sughero
ed è diciamo è anche c'è anche questa
eco diciamo alle alle spalle questo
omaggio john smith ma è un opera d arte
contemporanea nel cielo nero in questo
cielo nero campeggiano misteriosi
organismi c'è anche una caffettiera una
tazzina una matita
eccole c'è un paio di forbici
dall'impugnatura ergonomica
quindi diciamo oggetti che noi
riconosciamo che sono del nostro del
nostro presente insieme ad altre inedite
navicelle spaziali ora dei four nights
il giorno per la notte
che cosa succede beh c'è un'inversione
compiuta in fase di sviluppo un
inversione della pellicola che introduce
subito diciamo il tema della differenza
razziale
parliamo di un artista sudafricano
bianco nero in versione della pellicola
bianco nero il bianco del tavolo diventa
il nero il nero dell'universo il nero
della matita diventa il bianco di uno
shuttle
ecco ma cosa sono quelli quegli strani
questi strani punti nino cosa sono
questi strani puntini questi strani
organismi che che vagano in questo
universo nero e qui diciamo st l'intuito
visionario dell'artista
nel 2002 siamo nel 2002 johannesburg
william kentridge vivere a joannesburg e
questa città viene letteralmente invasa
dalle formiche c'è una vera e propria
invasione di formiche quindi un disastro
un disastro la gente nel pieno
dell'estate è invasa dalle dalle
formiche e qui e qui diciamo il talento
di reid intuito visionario dell'artista
è anche quello di saper trasformare la
vessazione in dono
questo è il grande grande salto
questi arabeschi disegnati dalle
formiche queste processioni fameliche
delle formiche sui tavoli sui pavimenti
dappertutto vengono seguiti dalla
telecamera di william kentridge
l'artista non sa ancora che cosa sta
facendo non ha la più pallida idea
o meglio non sa ancora che cosa sta
facendo ma in realtà un'idea comincia a
germinare nella sua mente la piccola
piccolo nucleo se queste formiche
vengono riprese da m sembrano del
delle auto in coda sulla tangenziale
se zoomiamo stringiamo il campo queste
formiche diventano degli alieni con
delle corazze che stanno invadendo un
pianeta un pianeta in asp inesplorato
cosa fa kentridge kentridge attira nel
suo studio
le formiche con una soluzione di acqua e
zucchero e comincia a tracciare
invisibile gli invisibili diciamo sul
pavimento appunto sulla sulla scrivania
che immediatamente le le formiche
ricalcano con le loro mandibole no e
cominciano a ricalcare i disegni
invisibili di kentridge ecco che l'idea
di un opera sul concetto di
colonizzazione si fa in luce da sola
praticamente no idea sul concetto di
colonizzazione essere sudafricani
comporta fare i conti con l'apartheid no
soprattutto diciamo
per chi da bianco privilegiato ha
combattuto apertamente il regime
kentridge e tra tra coloro che insieme
faccio altri due nomi super noti e super
importanti insieme a john maxwell coesi
ad esempio per premio nobel della
letteratura oa brighten breitenbach
poeta romanziere ma soprattutto
militante contro la discriminazione
razziale questi tre diciamo sono 3
bianchi che si sono battuti con ogni
mezzo contro la discriminazione razziale
e qui che entri rivive in questo modo
però quindi in questo modo lieve diciamo
rivive la colpa dei propri avi ovvero la
vergogna della supremazia bianca e lo fa
mettendo in scena in forma metaforica la
la profanazione compiuta dai padri
colonizzatori questo fa lo fa
ecco non appunto con
un'opera diciamo seriosa o impegnata lo
fa come potrebbe farlo diciamo un
goliarda celli diciamo l'ironia
goliardica di uno sperimentatore che ha
pochi mezzi ma tanta fantasia diciamo
che dà vita a un un video
scusate a un a un film perché poi di
fatto è un film
per meglio dire un'animazione che sembra
una cosa una via di mezzo tra
tra il film muto e il film di
fantascienza formiche in veste di
astronauti che colonizzano che invadono
un pianeta sconosciuto bianchi e neri
boeri e autoctoni
questo è diciamo il gioco la gamma
metaforica la questione è di chi sarà
ora questa nuova africa quest'africa chi
sarà allora questi di questi alieni poi
disegnano chiaramente dovreste vedere il
film insomma disegnano non soltanto
questo disegnano delle delle delle
figurine femminili certo punto c'è un
uomo vitruviano poi fanno costruiscono
delle delle costellazioni anche di td
inverosimili figure dello zodiaco
insomma ecco fanno fanno molte cose
la cosa interessante è che in queste
costellazioni terrestri di fatto questa
è una di queste formiche astronauti di
fatto sono degli alieni in un paese già
abitato perché nonostante tutto quello
che io vi ho detto fin ora è a nessuno
sfugge che quella una caffettiera che
quella una foto che quelle sono delle
forbici e che non ha tazzine di caffè
cioè quel pianeta e anche un pianeta
estremamente conosciuto per noi no
sono oggetti che riconosciamo ecco e
nello stesso tempo però diventa non
totalmente altro pensate che cosa è
capace di diventare ad esempio una
caffettiera nell'inversione della
pellicola no quale strane quale strana
figura quella strana navicella spaziale
qui c'è in gioco anche diciamo quella la
traslazione dell'oggetto noc e portato
in un altro contesto diventa totalmente
totalmente a
altra cosa no un oggetto di uso
funzionale un oggetto quotidiano
spostato in un'altra cornice può
diventare tutt'altro l'omaggio
ovviamente a l'iniziatore se vogliamo
dell'arte contemporanea marcel duchamp
coi suoi readymade lo prendi un
orinatoio lo metti nella cornice del
museo e diventa un'opera d'arte non c'è
anche questo sullo sfondo le immagini
sono a negativo vi ripeto c'è la
citazione della lanterna magica ma c'è
anche un'altra citazione importante che
quella delle ombre cinesi delle ombre
cinesi l'ombra l'ombra un elemento un
elemento determinante perché dico questo
beh perché centri qui assimila la
questione diciamo white white and
colored di fatto trasformandolo in un
conflitto interiore e come se qui ci
fosse un confronto serrato con il
proprio con il proprio lato oscuro lui
ha già dovuto lo dice in un'intervista
il rapporto con la nostra ombra è per me
un enigma memorabile dice ecco un enigma
memorabile il fatto è che l'uomo se ci
pensiamo è molto più propenso alla
diciamo la smemoratezza no a questo
proposito vi cito uno scrittore che io
amo molto un bravissimo scrittore
americano si chiama richard powers il
quale nel suo ultimo libro intitolato
generosity a proposito di questa
smemoratezza dice la seguente cosa
il segreto della sopravvive della
sopravvivenza sta nel dimenticare se
l'evoluzione favorisse la coscienza ogni
cosa dotata di spina dorsale si sarebbe
impiccata ad una trave del soffitto
milione di anni fa e gli invertebrati
avrebbero ripreso il comando
eccoli invertebrati
eccoli qua gli invertebrati piccole
formiche è stata terresti pronte a
dominarci allora
forse sto nei tempi abbondantemente
concluso forse il il lavoro dell'arte
consiste proprio in questo nell'aiutare
la memoria anche contro diciamo
l'interesse
l'interesse filogenetico della
discendenza diciamo aiutare la memoria
inseguire le nostre ombre per il piacere
ineguagliabile di non darsi pace e
facendolo riuscire a non suicidarsi
grazie
[Applauso]